and believe it or not that is actually
the message that
presidential candidate Nikki Haley is
also trying to convey to wealthy
Republican donors
it was revealed this week that Nikki
Haley the former ambassador to the U.N
former governor of South Carolina
current presidential candidate
sent a memo
to wealthy Republican donors basically
begging them for money
by trashing
both Ron DeSantis and Donald Trump
here's some of what the memo says here's
what the memo says about Trump
it's increasingly clear that Trump's
candidacy is more consumed by the
Grievances of the past and the promise
of more drama in the future rather than
a forward-looking vision for the
American people
no argument there like Nikki Haley your
campaign you hit the nail on the head
no critiques beautifully executed her
attack on Ron DeSantis Ron DeSantis
essentially launched his presidential
campaign with a national book tour
during this period and made one misstep
after another confirming what many
observers have long suspected he is not
ready for prime time
again no notes perfect I agree with
every word that you said there
especially because the not ready for
prime time thing is something I have
been saying for the last two years
then it gets even funnier then she goes
and then there are the others wait what
others
like that's it that's how it ends so
it's beautifully executed again Nikki
Haley top marks for this memo not that I
support you Canada to see but I gotta
say
you said all the right things because
here's what's happening
as I said this is a memo that she sent
to wealthy Republican donors Trump is
too much drama and too much baggage he's
in it for himself get rid of him
Ron DeSantis he's a blithering idiot
that is absolutely bumbling on the
national stage he's got no chance oh
there's some other people maybe but who
are they you don't know them I don't
know them so give me your money
and by the way Nikki Haley
um in the first six weeks of her
campaign raised 11 million dollars
Donald Trump only pulled in I think like
somewhere between six and nine million
in the first quarter of this year now
that doesn't include the massive
fundraising Hall that he has had since
the indictment
but had it not been for the indictment
were Trump according to his campaign
raised like 10 million dollars in two
weeks Nikki Haley would be out raising
Donald Trump right now
so Nikki Haley is not a candidate to
just laugh off as another has been she's
actually doing well
not in the poll
you know not where it matters but in the
fundraising Arena she's doing pretty
well you know she's got name recognition
she's traveling and she's been back to
Iowa a couple of times she's going out
there she's doing speeches something
that Trump is not
probably because he's got to worry about
all of his legal problems
but Nikki Haley right now in terms of
being a candidate again please don't
take this as I'm saying I support her or
I like anything she stands for but if we
take off our partisan blinders and just
analyze the campaign itself
she's doing everything right
so this letter attacking her opponents
to the donors that's a smart move
pointing out that she basically raised
more money than Trump is a smart move
she even said at one point like Donald
Trump had a pretty good uh first quarter
if you count being indicted as good
so she's going No Holds Barred right she
is absolutely let's take on Donald Trump
let me bloody him up let me show these
donors that I am the drama-free path
forward I am not out there like Ron
DeSantis looking like an idiot
I'm the real deal that is how she's
pitching herself and again based on her
pitch based on the money that she's
raising
pretty obvious that she is doing a
decent job with this the weather is
about to start warming up and that often
means sweating and chafing and sticking
sheath is the men's underwear that once
and for all puts an end to all of that
nonsense our sponsor sheath underwear
has designed unique boxer briefs with an
ergonomic compartment built to keep
everything separate and dry and cool and
comfortable by allowing air to circulate
everywhere it needs to be no more
readjusting all day sheath offers a huge
variety of designs and patterns over
half a million pairs have already been
sold also check out their super
comfortable bamboo t-shirts sheath has
amazing customer service super fast
shipping along with over twenty thousand
five star reviews sheath is also
actively working with multiple
non-profits that deal with mental health
and homelessness which you support Court
when you get sheath underwear I've had a
great experience with sheath underwear I
know you will too head on over to
sheathunderwear.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman for 20 off the link is down
below